the web benefits from a healthy
relationship between browser vendors and
web developers and framework authors and
their users are often at the forefront
of trying to find a healthy balance
between DX and UX so today we thought
we'd bring along a few folks from
frameworks libraries and their users to
have a chat about what the better future
could look like so joining us on the
stage we first of all have Andrew Clark
from reacts Android next up we've got
Jason Miller from reacts we have Steve
Orville from the polymer team Rob
Wormald from angular Tracy Lee from this
JavaScript and rxjs chatty tala from
glimmer and ember Shawn Larkin
representing PJs and web pack
[Music]
malte Google the tech lead of apps and
finally Alex Russell from the chrome
team lover of frameworks all right sit
down so thank you to everyone that
managed to get their questions in today
we have a very special prize for the
best question courtesy of Alex the very
best question today gets a very average
Moto G for phone that's gonna stay over
here for now awesome so let's let's get
into it very first question that came in
was which features if any would make
your life as a framework author or user
easier if they were added to the
JavaScript language or web platform more
broadly Jason you want to start us off
sure is there's been some stuff going
around recently about a proposal called
Dom change list and I think one of the
end games of this spec is basically a
way to serialize a set of mutations to
the Dom one of the end results of this
would be we can start to run more
application code in a web worker web
workers have existed for a really long
time and are strangely underused in our
community so it's a primitive that
whether it's polyfills are implemented
in browsers once we've got some of these
things in place we can start to offload
a lot of work off of the main thread and
reduce jank on mobile so that's like a
huge thing that I'm hopeful for what do
you think it is about web workers that
have like stopped them from getting as
much traction as they could they're
scary also you know by default when you
construct a worker you have to give it a
URL and it's it's pretty easy like get a
blob URL for an inline string but it's
not like the default behavior so for
where there's like a task lit API that
might be proposed to solve that that
would be another huge feature so that a
framework shipping could instantiate a
worker with some code in it and that
wouldn't be a weird thing right that
would be expected so ok so web workers
Rob on the angular side did you have any
opinions about that I know that angular
is Stora Cleavon trying to invest in web
workers yeah I would second the the DOM
angellist api would be amazing for us
look I think we could put it in tomorrow
and it would be it would be ready to go
so that'd be a big one and then
observables would be the other big one
that we'd like to see angular developers
using a ton of that they seem to really
enjoy it
it would be nice to not have to ship
that code and not pay for those bytes
and I think it opens up a lot of
interesting things on API is like
intersection observer and you tation
observer I look at those and go those
are kind of perfect for the sort of
thing we're talking about so those would
be the big two for me is there something
specific other than having to ship it
like solve this problem in user lands
that stripping observables in a browser
what would bring I could probably talk
for like an hour about that I think for
me that to me it's kind of the same
thing that we went through from
callbacks to promises when we got a type
and you get a thing you can pass around
and treat like a real thing I feel like
we need the same thing for events right
and that's more or less than observable
is for me is that get a handle on the
thing be able to pass around tree like
an object and it really changes how you
think about doing complex event things
drag-and-drop all these really
highfalutin animation stuff we all want
to do this interaction stuff I think it
becomes much easier when you have a
primitive for handling really what's
delivering you shadows guy was curious
what from the the glimmer and Ember side
do you feel is missing so again the
changeless stuff we actually have like a
straw man like implementation of this in
the glimmer VM a lot of the work that
we're doing on the glimmer side is
instead of compiling like a template
like how vast majority of these
frameworks authors you know projects do
what we are trying to do is compile
templates directly into like a bytecode
format and so the changeless proposal is
more kind of a line with that because
the whole idea is that you would build
up all the operations that you need to
like manipulate the Dom that's a typed
array you can transfer that across you
know different workers and everything
like that and then apply it on the main
thread so yeah I think that change lists
or something like the change list would
be I think great okay so we've got
change list consensus and we just ship
that now I think yeah you do change this
Plus worker dumb there you go change
little worker dumb Alex do any opinions
on
changeless no it's very straight fake
bugger for its terrible down that you
want them Tracy we so observables were
mentioned I know that in the rxjs
community observables are a big thing
there as well do you need takes on you
know our art our observable something
browser vendors for seriously you taking
a look at baking in I totally think so I
mean I know there's a
tc39 observable spec happening and
hopefully that moves somewhere and just
earlier rob was talking about hopefully
how are you guys gonna champion a door I
think we may it well we're looking at it
so hopefully that land soon observables
in the browser but I think if we're able
to sort of start getting those types of
things to happen that are sort of more
native than what's gonna happen is I
think hopefully the ability for people
to use our XJS and the learning curve is
a little bit less daunting yep awesome
Malta so I was I was curious from the
amp side other other capabilities you
feel or missing so what I would like to
say because ever mentioned workers for
like what browser windows could do is
and hear us
like we all talk about workers the
developer experience and dev tools isn't
great yet so if you could invest in the
future and say like maybe in the air
people actually use workers but then
have the dev tools already be good that
would be amazing
I also have like something am doesn't
really need it but I think everyone kind
of wants this which is just really good
week maps so they launched a feature
called week nib
that's not actually what you usually
would consider this so just having like
a cash they can put stuff in and maybe
it's still there but you know not
considered by a college collection like
if you build something like relay or you
know even Redux I think everyone kind of
wants this and it's not you know pin
coming and that's really sad okay so
it's really creating at this uh so Steve
that's curious did you feel like there
any capabilities missing from the
platform that would benefit folks that
are writing you know applications using
web components or polymer yeah I mean I
think I definitely a second the
JavaScript API is that are mentioned I
mean we think a little bit more about
the Dom here and just say like you don't
there's tons of cool stuff that we run
into when
during that I think would be nice to add
to the platform specifically stuff like
you know a lot of the stuff that native
elements can do that we can't do in
custom element land there's cool stuff
that like the dialogue element can do
that we can't do render stuff on top of
other things in input element of course
a new infinity stuff be awesome to
deconstruct that and really add that to
our tool kit you know so that we can use
that as developers and anything from the
react side yeah things that the browser
can do that frameworks can do API is
that expose that I think we're always
exciting to us our favorite our current
favorite API browser API is request idle
callback that is we use it at that
everywhere that's kind of core to how
we're thinking about basically what our
goal is with react right now is did
everyone enjoy that image async feature
that y'all talked about what if you can
make any component async and just make
any of your components stop blocking the
main thread so scheduling primitives
like request out a callback there's a
really cool proposal I think the what WG
I was get the different things confused
but there's a really cool proposal
proposal called async append which i
think is a very interesting problem
space this basically lets you build up
this tree of Dom whether you using react
or whatever you could mainly create this
and asynchronously append it into the
Dom you get a promise that says once all
of the layout and everything has been
done by the browser and then once the
promise resolves you can decide when you
want to actually commit that change or
actually flush the changes it's really
cool reading that document cuz it's kind
of just a description of what we're
trying to do with react as well but
that's the type of thing that react
can't do or a framework can't do is all
unless we implement layout which maybe
we well but realistically for now we
can't do that so that those are the
kinds of guys that we get really excited
about so we thought we saw some
convergence on Dom change list is async
append something that any other famous
we see lots of nodding and fingers and
alex is also happy yeah that's great
okay we've got we've got some
convergence on this that's great let's
let's move on to another questions so
folks are wondering what criteria should
you use if you're trying to select the
JavaScript library or framework to build
a new app
today and given that he's just written a
blog post about performance budget so I
was curious on Alex's take on this and
then everybody else's you might get a
different answer depending on who you
ask
today I work in chrome I used to work on
frameworks and working on a browser
means you represent the user and so I
wind up representing the users interest
in a lot of these conversations and the
way I see people constructing the
applications today is incredibly
well-suited to the computers and
networks that we were building and using
about five years ago six years ago right
networked computers that were had
reasonable and good stable latency fast
pipes copious CPU relatively small
screens compared to the amount that
you've had to paint so that's not the
world we live in today mobile is much
much much much much much much much much
much harder than any of that ever was
the latency on the networks is terrible
the types are smaller and variable and
so you know we've been working with lots
of partners for a lot of years and our I
think the way I would think about this
is frameworks take some amount of your
headroom how much headroom do you have
is the next obvious question and I think
you have if you're gonna be building a
framework based site you've got about a
hundred and thirty kilobytes on the wire
cheez-it so when you're selecting a
framework I think one of your primary
questions should be how much of that
hundred and thirty K that you need to
stuff all of your Styles all of your
critical java scripts all of your data
all of your markup templates application
logic everything has to go in the 130
kilobytes how much of that is your
framework taking is a question you
should ask so one thing I was curious
Andrea about this you're staring at us
now next to me one thing I was curious
about from the react side so we
obviously see like a lot of applications
being started today that are targeting
mobile using reacts and and you know
they're making a bunch of ecosystem
choices about you know using Redux etc
do you think that folks understand the
costs of the ecosystem pieces they're
using when it comes to trying to target
mobile is this the scenario that need do
I think people understand this problem
um probably depends who you talk to one
like downside I guess of the react
ecosystem historically relative to the
way maybe Emperor view I think for you
does a good job with this is that we
have like resisted the frameworks like I
know you put frameworks and libraries in
the title we've resisted like the
frameworks label for a long time because
react was designed to kind of fit into
the architecture of Facebook like from
four years ago five years ago so in the
beginning like we never built like react
apps as like single page applications we
were building like little little tiny
views all over a larger server rendered
app so the first people that built like
server rendered at applications were
like way out ahead of us so we never
like provide our own router we never
provide our own solution for data
fetching so I think what to the extent
that people don't care about this enough
and there may be in the reacting system
I think that's kind of a consequence of
that and the future I think with things
like create react app and really cool
projects like next j/s gatsby that are
starting to give a more framework a
holistic approach to how you're supposed
to do service workers or server-side
rendering which is I think is really
exciting untapped area still or data
fetching or whatever I think that's
going to be a really exciting important
area in the next year or so one thing
that you touched on was things like next
Jas being a good place to maybe so you
see that as being a good place for us to
try defining perhaps well it paths for
people that are trying to you know
deliver applications on mobile how do
you what was the word you said well let
well it pass okay I don't know what that
is an opinionated path for fix well it's
a little bit okay yes like a cowpath
okay I respond to animal metaphors okay
yeah I think that think we have resisted
track taking like super strong opinions
on things especially because the
infrastructure use at Facebook is not we
don't really use webpack even though we
think web pack is really great so we've
resisted giving
too many opinions but I can see us like
shifting more in that direction there
are a lot of things like server-side
rendering streaming service at rendering
data fetching the data management code
delivery like Sam was talking about
earlier there's a lot of these things
that are really the same problem space
or overlapping the problem space that we
don't have a great way of like pushing
our solution or our vision of what that
should be because we don't control like
a framework II framework so that's why
next and stuff really excites me in the
reactor space because they are offering
a little bit more of this and I think we
will maybe start to dip our toe even
further than creative react up in the
future that's awesome
Jason so pre axis is in a similar spot
with respect to you know technically
being a library what is your take on
this yes I'd say if you're if you're
making a technology decision about how
you are going to structure your
applications if you're picking something
important like your view renderer but
what you want to know is when I'm finish
this and I ship my version one how large
is it gonna be if you're picking a
library you probably need to look at
what the what the rest of the options
you have are in that library space so if
you're going with react you need to say
okay how how large is a common router do
I have a decent selection there you know
for the various CLI tools or server-side
rendering tools like next what is the
end result of those kind of ecosystem
you know approaches because at the end
of the day if you end up going with next
the size of react may not even have that
much of an effect on your bundle it's
more the size of next that you want to
be concerned with and so it like even if
you're not doing server-side rendering
or next or Gatsby or whatever look at
the common CLI tool look at the
boilerplate you're gonna use and see if
there's like a metric you can derive
from that not just the library cool
let's uh let's switch up topics let's
talk about Interop so framework Interop
web component Interop there's been an
interesting hot topic in the community
thanks for a while Tracy I was curious
what's your take on this
there spec to you like is is it
important for frameworks to interrupt
together if you've got teams that are
working in you know react and view in
practice cetera is is that important as
a thing for friend developers I think
you look at a lot of large companies who
just do JavaScript so a lot of companies
try to say okay I'm just gonna go the
Ember road I'm just gonna go to the
reactor I'm just gonna go this route but
then you have a lot of people who just
have sort of disparate teams who try to
say okay I have this angular app what's
the you know what's this what's the
library I'm gonna build with all these
components and do I stick react in
angular or or what do i do there so I
guess it would be nice I mean I think
it'd be nicer for some developers and I
think that there are a lot of solutions
especially in the corporate world that
people have sort of stuck together it'd
be nice that those were sort of more
forward or maybe maybe you guys can come
up with a solutions to do that or maybe
a web tech can solve all the problems
since Tracy put you on the spot shop
what is what is web packs but what is
your take on on framework Interop you
know I think one is the biggest so okay
I'll speak from experience what we do at
Microsoft so we have over 98 products
that ship in production that use webpack
but no single one is the same and one of
the biggest initiatives that is taking a
significant amount of time is trying to
unify some sort of component library or
system I think some of the biggest debt
that companies struggle with and even
one like Microsoft is that we have to be
able to move fast add features but then
as platforms change or features are
added or new frameworks you know crop up
we want to be able to take advantage of
these technologies but in a way that can
still be agnostic and provide interrupts
between teams so like I have my own
opinions and you know I think view is
really gonna blaze the trail in terms of
how we might see kind of a generic
statically analyzed kind of Rosetta
Stone for lots of different frameworks
to consume components and you know Jason
I have worked on it a couple times yeah
so you know he's already has a his a
loader power bi web pack that's already
taking a view component and importing it
into a project and it works so I mean I
there's a huge amount of you know
opportunities for lots of people to
explore
so Jason I was actually curious you've
you from the pre-act side of viewpoint
of you've you've kind of been interested
in web component support I think that
pre acts been been doing a decent job of
looking at Interop you've also been
again working with Shawn on ideas around
you know how can we take inspiration
from things like the HTML imports
approach that you know libraries that
polymer have heavily been using and
bringing to other frameworks could you
talk a little bit about your opinions on
what the future direction of that might
look like
sure so for me a part of the hip part of
the win here is we essentially have a
compiler model right that the web is
obviously a target we write code for but
it's also a target we compile code for
not just with web assembly and these
types of things but even just compiling
to JavaScript but if we if we take a
look at the way that we're using these
compilers and we try to model our input
after existing specifications like if
you have a compiler that takes in
something that is essentially a
serialized web component right an HTML
file with JavaScript CSS and a template
in it that's an understandable
independent layer you don't need to know
how whatever the framework that renders
it at you know after compilation works
you could just sort of know how web
components works and if the framework
adequately implements slots then you
know if you know how well it slot works
then you know how this file works I
think that Shawn had mentioned Rosetta
Stone I think that's a good analogy for
this if we can start to converge at
least a little bit on what a component
looks like right across all these
different technologies what is the
substrate that they're all built on then
we can start to kind of you know cross
compile between them you know you could
write a user interface components
library with you know beautiful CSS and
encapsulation and some behaviors and
then compile it to whatever framework
you're currently using and it won't
matter you know ten years from now you
could compile it something else mm-hmm
Steve I'm curious about your take on
this there's there's the cross
compilation idea and then there's you
know just having everything work
magically at runtime
what does we take on the shape this
brochure I mean as you guys probably
know web cubes are web components are
kind of designed to solve this problem
so a little bit makes me slightly sad
that you know it's everybody is not just
gravitating towards towards it on the
other hand I think you know the
is evolving it's taken a long time and I
think it's getting there and hopefully
we will evolve it still and make it a
satisfying answer to this issue I think
one of the places that polymer has seen
a lot of adoption actually is in you
know big corporations where they just
have this polyglot of different stuff
and they just need a technology that
works without you know wherever the Dom
is gonna work and this is really where
something like that web account is shine
and I think this is something where like
as now that this is kind of the year of
the web components specs being
implemented what widely you know I hope
there will be more interest among the
other frameworks here and I think
there's there's I want to give a shout
out Taylor didn't talk earlier to you to
the custom elements everywhere that Rob
Dodson has done which is I think that we
took a little bit for granted the fact
that hey we're the platform you know
everybody's just gonna work with us and
I think you know it's like to a lot of
you know different approaches this is
sort of a scary concept that now an
element in the platform can be anything
it can be whatever and I think this is
partly incredibly powerful because it's
sort of this democratic process of the
cream of the crop can rise and and you
know but at the same time it's also like
but that thing could do anything it's
kind of scary do I really want to use
that and this is where I think the
approach between custom elements
everywhere is really interesting because
it kind of is this idea that you know
this the framework authors and the
community of developers making these
melons really have to meet in the middle
you know and establish best practices
such that you know it makes sense do
these use these things all together and
we can all benefit so hopefully that
happens Rob so angular has been
investing in trying to improve their
Interop with custom elements mmm
components in general for the last Wow
what's what's your take on this so I
kind of feel like the Rosetta Stone that
that Sean was talking about I think
that's what a custom element is I think
that that that is and I don't think this
group of people would agree on many
things right completely I guess the
group but I do think that we've all more
or less landed on this idea that there
are events and there are props or
property whatever gonna call them right
we all kind of an API that if you squint
it's more or less the same
so to maybe make your ear a bit better
today a little bit better like I can I
can say that our team has decided that
you know we've we've always consumed web
components that
day one designs decision in angular I
talked to enough big companies I'm sure
you know companies that the Palmer in
that have these very disparity because
systems have a dozen different
frameworks I think it's very sad as a
web developer that everybody has to
rewrite the date picker and every
framework that exists right if I do one
thing as I webbed up like somebody who
works on the web now we can just write
one date picker that's awesome and then
everywhere I'll just quit right so so
from our perspective right angular is a
is a framework II framework as you said
right we do try to solve a lot of these
problems and so for us it's you know I
think our bread and butter is these big
applications every likes to build but
for me would be great if angular
components could be spit out as web
components right it's it's a thing you
look at it and it's a no-brainer and so
six weeks ago we started really looking
into this I've been complaining about it
for eighteen months I said Alex Russell
when I joined Google that we're gonna
make this happen and finally it's
happening so you'll be able to write an
angular component and spit it out as a
custom element and I think that the most
important thing about that the the kind
of crux to all this custom element stuff
is that nobody has to know anything
about how the component was implemented
to make it work because everybody in
this room already knows how the Dom
works right and if that becomes the
common API well talk to it doesn't
really matter what happens inside of the
component right we can all have this
rosetta stone we can all talk and we can
write one datepicker and everybody can
be happy right on that note it sounds
like there's there some some interesting
convergence on the rosetta stone I don't
idea I'm curious from the react
perspective what's what's react to take
on web components yes we have a slightly
different take web components are really
cool I think they definitely solve they
solved the encapsulation problem and
they solve the consumption problem where
you should be able to consume a
component have to learn 15 different
ways to consume a component and surely
you can wrap any react up and a web
component it's not not that hard the
question is whether or not we should
replace like react components as a
primitive for building your application
with just writing a bunch of web
components and on that note we're not as
convinced because we use
I could be wrong but I think another
selling point for web components is that
perhaps it obviates the need for a
virtual Dom or for us to have to manage
your own like like parallel and memory
representations of your view and on that
on that part web components don't solve
that for us so cuz we use our internal
instances not just for encapsulation but
we use it for memorization we use it for
you know computing changes we use it for
scheduling that's the big one I don't
know if you all have heard of this
research effort we had to rewrite react
but we're moving in a direction with
react 16 and going forward where we're
going to have a sync by default
rendering and what this means is we need
to be able to do we're gonna do all of
our rendering work inside of requests
idle callback basically and in order to
do that you need like this double pass
kind of rendering system where you have
two phases you only ever async render
phase where you do most of your
expensive work it's all in request auto
call back or maybe in the future it's on
a web worker or whatever and then you
have a synchronization phase where once
you can compute all of your mutations
into a dom changeless maybe you can sing
synchronously flush all of them all at
once and that's the type of architecture
which we're really excited about there's
a lot of cool features that you can
build on top of this but it's not really
possible without implementing your own
data structures so we're like thumbs up
on web components but we don't think it
replaces the need to have our own data
structures alex ribbony takes on this
yeah I mean so um full disclosure
Dimitri glazkov Alex komoroske and I
started the project at Google that sort
of started the web components effort um
we're sorry pologize you know catch me
later buy you beer I don't think web
components actually have any bearing on
whether or not you should have a virtual
Dom right this virtual DOM becomes an
implementation detail about how your
component decides to handle getters
setters attributes setting and all the
stuff web components as an
implementation give you a surface area
that everybody knows as well
so you can just reuse the day picker
from wherever and then how you want to
handle that question about how state
gets handled inside of your component is
now up to you it doesn't do any global
coordination so I think this is one of
these places where web components
disaggregate a bunch of things that
frameworks used to do frameworks have
traditionally taken a bunch of different
different responsibilities between
ensuring compatibility across the Dom
giving you a component model in the
first place making sure that those
component updates are coordinated in
various places doing data distribution
and event handling and web component
sort of disentangle a couple of those
and leave you with a few of those
problems they don't solve everything so
a few of those still have to happen um
and it's interesting to see how the
various frameworks are sort of
reorienting themselves now the web
components are kind of the same so yeah
I think you know I think I've seen lots
of people you know sketchy asses doing
this great work with are using virtual
Dom inside of custom elements which is
super cool there may be using pre-act
internally which is you know not
removing a virtual Dom but it does leave
that global coordination question open
cool and uh sorry I just gonna say it
just a sentence on the on the interrupt
thing just to go back a little bit um I
just want to I'm gonna sound like a
broken record but one of the thing that
we've found that it's interesting about
interrupts is is this coordination
problem at Facebook we use react
everywhere but the other framework that
we use is server-side rendering and if
you think about it both of we have this
system called big pipe the thing about
both of these are asynchronous systems
and it becomes a really interesting
problem how to coordinate to incres
asynchronous render so that things are
popping in on the screen at different
times okay and circling back to malta
amp is one of the largest consumers of
custom elements I'm kind of curious on
your take about his Rob's so I I just
had this conversation with a product
manager saying hey we didn't they take
her an amp and I'm like oh my god not
again and what we ended up doing was
taking the Airbnb react date picker
using its pre act so it's not actually
like 60 kilobytes and putting into
custom element and because and it works
fine like empties everything the date
picker and and that is like I'm worried
or worried about the people
put all these massive frameworks and
these little encapsulated things I think
we need to understand that just because
something is great than the interrupt
level and we don't have to make a new
date picker doesn't mean you don't even
application framework no on the other
hand like amp right now it doesn't
actually allow you to write code in any
other framework
um so interrupt is a bit awkward but I
think what our goal is is in the long
term that you could just use you know
react to render this stuff that you want
to change and document it runtime like I
think the current state is not where we
want this to be that's just you know the
thing we could implement in fall of 2015
switching gears up that we we are
running a little bit over that's gonna
take one or two final questions what
impact is webassembly going to have if
any on JavaScript frameworks and
libraries
Chad do you have any takes on those so I
think webassembly is kind of interesting
there's certain things I really like to
talk today basically it's not a
replacement for JavaScript if there's in
places where you need the performance I
think it will play a larger part of you
know maybe not you know every day
developers writing it but framework
authors may you opt into writing in a
little bit of C code to maybe eke out a
little bit of more performance this is
like some things that were experimenting
with with glimmers in very high critical
performance scenarios we want try to eke
out as much as possible
you got enough performance as possible
awesome
Jason did you have any other takes on
web assembly I just something that came
up I'm like a total web assembly new but
something came up over lunch you laughs
yeah I know the API it's about it also I
wouldn't trust myself to write native
code no so but one one interesting area
that got touched on was for something
like a polyfill for a really performance
critical feature having the ability to
write at least parts of the polyfill and
web assembly could be really compelling
we were talking about Dom change list if
there's you know difficult Asians or
something that needs to happen in there
or the creation of that that array
buffer if that's better done in
see and webassembly is available why
wouldn't you do it
seems like it'd be powerful there so our
final question is is not strictly going
to do with api's but we had a question
around you know what can we as a group
do to improve diversity in open source
which i think is a really important
topic and something that i personally
love to see us make some traction on
Tracy I was interested in your take on
this and you know I think there's
there's a lot of really great programs
out like as I'm a Google developer group
organizer and there's a woman tech
makers initiative that happens and it's
a really great way to sort of you know
bring woman developers together and give
them a safe space to learn I think if
you talk to women across women and just
everybody in general but I got one cuz
I'm a female if you talk to a woman in
general you know everybody has varying
ideas of acceptance and inclusion and
what it should be and what it shouldn't
be so I think you know not really
forcing your opinions on women but just
giving them a way for you know them to
contribute the way they want to I think
which is also encouragement in general I
think in our industry you know we have
this diversity problem and a lot of
companies are looking for these senior
developers where when you actually look
at our industry you see a lot of junior
female developers coming in and what we
need to do is sort of somehow figure out
a way that we're able to encourage these
unit developers so that we can build
senior developers and I think that's the
biggest problem right now that's the
biggest disconnect we have I agree with
that Shawn you also this is a problem
that you you have some thoughts on yeah
I mean like if it wasn't for open source
I wouldn't be here I'd still be like in
tech support or you know like just say
oh you know doing whatever and so it's
like and thanks to you know a little bit
of my privilege what why does this have
to be a unique story for for just you
know myself like we should be able to
not only elevate the opportunities for
every single person to be able to
receive the same blessings
many of us have just by being involved
and passionate about something and so
one of the things that were you know
that we've seen is that we have specific
outreaches for webpack not only that
span gender or race but even just
countries like we have initiative called
webpack Africa that we're starting and a
gentleman named prosper if you haven't
met him
where's you raise their hand maybe he's
at he's back there somewhere
he's helping lead that organization and
their goal was we need to prepare people
for the web for the next billion people
and so it's like that means that we
could have the opportunity to elevate
somebody to a whole new life opportunity
for the next million contributions or
developers and so like we want to find
as many ways possible to essentially
elevate or provide more opportunity so
that these success stories don't have to
be unique they don't have to be rare on
that note we are out of time please join
me in giving a hand to all of our
panelists you're very kind enough to
take time out to come here today
[Music]